madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce vendredi 14
septembre
nous reviendrons bien sûr ce soir sur la
disparition d'un géant de la télévision
jacques martin nous a quittés la nuit
dernière à l'âge de 74 ans un artiste
complet qui a marqué plusieurs
générations de téléspectateurs
nous allons revenir dans une longue page
spéciale sur son parcours
réactions et émotions d'anonymes mais
également ceux de ses proches qui
témoigneront dans ce journal
dans l'actualité également aujourd'hui
une libération qui fait polémique celle
d'un homme jacques maire condamné il ya
un an à 20 ans de réclusion pour les
meurtres de deux femmes
son jugement a été annulée pour un
simple vice de procédure un sourire
enfin dans le climat un peu triste du
sport français avec le titre de champion
du monde de judo obtenu par teddy riner
titre dans la catégorie de plus de 100
kg à seulement 18 ans il apparaît
désormais comme l'héritier de david
douillet et puis nous terminerons cette
édition avec un retour sur l'incroyable
carrière de la diva maria callas elle
disparaissait il ya 30 ans une légende
et un destin tragique qui ont fait
d'elle un mythe absolu 1 1
ce jeune homme qui va se jeter au centre
du plateau sur la scène qui l'attend
c'est josée bastien
ah c'est pas grave pourquoi il faut pas
embrasser les garçons ils sont pas bien
oui tu gagnes le centre des plateaux
jean-sébastien vous êtes la voisine du
jeune trompettiste et que c'est moi j'ai
un peu monté sur votre m'arrive et je le
ferai remonter à la fin et on papa est
pas là si oui le gie qui là-bas à temps
mais à quoi ressemble la vie ressemble
en rien à ce qu'il fait on papa à mont
de marsan comme métier
ils regardent la télé d'être ainsi à ses
yeux
j'ai eu le but yazd a dit didier allard
on applaudit mesdames messieurs
il faut reconnaître qu'il y à des hommes
comme cela qu'ils finissent par faire
partie de la famille jacques martin
s'était invité à la table de millions de
français chaque dimanche durant des
années
l'un de ces rendez vous était bien sûr
cette émission de variétés l'école des
fans qui est entré dans toutes les
mémoires mais il y aura également
dimanche martin ou encore l'émission
satirique le petit rapporteur sur
laquelle nous reviendrons bien sûr
jacques martin est donc mort la nuit
dernière à biarritz à l'âge de 74 ans
c'est l'une des grandes figures de la
télévision qui disparaît un homme
cultivé qui aimait rire et faire rire
avant tout bref toute une époque
emmanuel lambert frédéric basket jacques
martin s'est dit l'empereur de la petite
lucarne pendant un quart de siècle il a
su retenir des millions de français
devant leur écran télévision tous les
dimanches
tout l'après-midi oublier ce qui s'est
passé pendant la semaine
nous sommes là pour vous distraire et
uniquement pour vous distraire vois que
vous avez des atouts beaucoup
d'impertinence et surtout un flair a un
flair pour débusquer les talents de
desproges à ruquier le résultat des
émissions populaires et insolente
ce jour là la cible c'est l'armée
reposer alors oui quand les gens disent
ça quand même à casser les noix novembre
1960 télé strasbourg
vinci cédait 3 les crises et à toi à
vingt sept ans jacques martin débarque
pour la première fois en noir et blanc
dans la télévision enfants à lyon il
rêvait d'être chef d'orchestre mais un
certain pierre tchernia à une autre idée
il voit en lui
l'amuseur public numéro 1 un très bon
choix
une dose d'insolence un soupçon de
dérision la recette est un succès enfin
on apprend que jamais vu qu'on se fasse
pas de parler l'anglais fait nous quoi
journal télévisé décaler le petit
rapporteur secoue les téléspectateurs un
peu plus tard avec ainsi font font font
la joyeuse bande refait le monde mais
moi ce que je préfère c'est de jafar
time it à tort fantaisiste iconoclaste
provocateur et il a été cependant de
nombreuses nombreuses années 1975
peut-être l'émission la plus
emblématique la récréation a lieu le
dimanche après midi
parents enfants personne ne fait l'école
buissonnière ils sont très assidus 10
millions de téléspectateurs en moyenne
l'école des fans fait les beaux jours
d'antenne 2 tu vois ça c'est exactement
la petite fille que j'aurais aimé
rencontrer pour jouer avec elle quand
j'avais tonnage et ce jour là
vanessa paradis s'est tant fait sa
première télé qu'est ce que tu vas
chanter
voilà emilie jolie durablement installé
sur la deuxième chaîne jacques martin
orchestre tous les après-midis
dominicaux pendant 25 ans la lorgnette
thé dansant le monde est à vous
incroyable mais vrai les émissions se
succèdent au théâtre de lempire à chaque
fois des succès incroyables des
souvenirs merveilleux de d'un homme
multiple étrange talentueux tout était
vraiment un festival d'hiver aura été le
maître mot de jacques martin
avec ses 40 ans de carrière il restera
une institution une légende du petit
écran
et quand viendra un bon jour le grand
départ pour très loin dans un coin où
s'arrête le dernier quart le dirait j'ai
rempli mon franc gamme
monsieur la bombe ce soir
je dirais j'ai rempli mon bonheur
voilà quelques éléments d'un parcours
riche parcours d'un comédien qui avait
rencontré la télévision qui en avait
fait sa maison son terrain de jeu avec
nous tout d'abord un premier invité
stéphane collaro bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous avez longtemps travaillé
avec jacques martin quel était votre
premier sentiment ce matin lorsque vous
avez appris cette nouvelle
c'est à dire celui du coeur terriblement
serré parce que il ya une chose qui est
étonnant c'est que cette complicité avec
jacques martin qui a duré cinq ou six
ans vraiment quand elle était totale et
complète
elle remonte maintenant à 30 ans et j'ai
l'impression que c'était que c'était
hier et que donc on m'enlevait une
petite partie de ma vie
bon maintenant ça l'a dit jacques martin
je lirai toujours dans mon coeur est ce
que je garderai spécialement c'est celui
totalement pétillant et magique des
années 70 ça c'est quand même un grand
grand grand grand souvenir pour moi que
je n'oublierai jamais ces femmes que
l'on ressent aujourd'hui une vraie
émotion populaire est ce que vous pensez
que jacques martin avait conscience de
cette popularité qu'il avait façonné
ben oui en fait je crois que la
popularité elle le rendait heureux et
malheureux en même temps c'est à dire
que jacques adorait être un comédien
populaire et c'était un énorme comique
populaire mais en même temps il aurait
il aurait bien aimé être respecté pour
ses talents d'auteur pour son
intelligence pour sa culture et donc et
chaque fois qu'il essayait de faire
quelque chose d'un petit peu plus éviter
qu'un petit peu plus cultivé et ben il
perdait son public populaire et tout ça
c'est le contrarier quand même beaucoup
mais c'était un énorme un énorme comique
populaire
alors on va vous retrouver dans un autre
grand auteur on va vous retrouver dans
un instant laurent gerra et daniel
prévost seront également avec nous mais
avant cela la popularité justement de
jacques martin il avait su fidéliser à
large public avec ses différents rendez
vous du dimanche voyons comment les uns
et les autres les anonymes son public
ont reçu la nouvelle de sa mort
témoignages recueillis par marie jo
jouant et régis mater
ah bon numéro 4 je mélangeais la
convaincant mais qu'elle met des frais
tels les pantalons des jupes mais
jacques martin vient de mourir
non non non non là je m'attends jacques
martin c'était un grand bonheur
le grand bonhomme de la télé les marchés
l'affairé remet ce soir avec mon
appareil pour la première fois devant
vous tentez un décollage sans visibilité
le commandant martin et son équipage
sont heureux de vous accueillir à bord
je retiens qu'il a fait beaucoup rire
on m'a fait beaucoup rire tracé sur 160
l'or va être quelqu'un de formidable qui
nous a fait de belles des missions qui
nous a amusés nul n'ignore en effet
qu'un bon journal se fabrique toujours
en piquant les meilleures idées des
confrères on voit ça que martin c'était
quelqu'un de très caustique de trait qui
à l'ancien quelque chose de la
télévision française à quelqu'un qui se
fait guère populaire et vous tapez cela
qu allez vous y êtes
attention jacques maintenance etc le
dimanche c'est l'enfance et c'est la
psychologie cc beaucoup de choses
jacques martin l'ontt non
après connus ont disparu
leurs chansons compte encore
dans les veines
alors avec nous maintenant laurent gerra
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous il y à
quelques temps dans une émission
spéciale à lyon avec michel drucker vous
aviez dit que jacques martin était en
fait votre papa de télévision c'est cela
ça me fait vraiment bizarre d'entendre
sa voix parce que jacques martin était
quelqu'un du music hall avant tout c'est
quelqu'un qui venait du music hall qui
aimait les artistes et qui savait
mélanger les gens et quand moi je me
suis retrouvé un jour passer une
audition avec jacques martin déjà ce qui
nous a rapprochés c'est qu'on était
lyonnais tous les deux et qu'on avait un
esprit à la fois provincial et on arrive
avec notre petite valise et je il a été
très très touchant avec moi très hâte à
chauray j'ai beaucoup beaucoup appris et
cette force du mot populaire que vous
aimez beaucoup également populaire
absolument et puis surtout
irrévérencieux parce que jacques pouvait
être irrévérencieux mais il pouvait se
le permettre parce qu'il avait cette
culture cette intelligence et ce recul
par rapport aux choses et puis à ce
métier aussi
alors c'est ça qui nous a marqué son
intelligence mais également parfois son
sale caractère ont dit oui mais c'était
légitime c'est moi je retiens surtout
les grands fous rires qu'on a eus
ensemble quand on faisait ainsi font
font font stéphane collaro parlait du
petit rapporteur
j'espère qu'on avait su retrouver la
veine du petit rapporteur en riant parce
que il nous disait vraiment d'aller loin
je pense qu'au petit rapporteur il aller
loin mais il avait il aimait ça il
aimait ce côté subversif il aimait cet
esprit frondeur de la france d'ailleurs
qui disait on est des enfants de molière
on sera toujours chance au nez sur
l'actualité jacquet mais ce mot chance
au nez parce que il aimait ce moquer des
institutions et il pouvait passer
effectivement avec une élégance total
d'une dan airs d'opéra parce que c'était
un mélomane et il aimait l'art lyrique
un air d'opéra à une énormité avec une
aisance incroyable alors vous restez
avec nous avant de retrouver stéphane
collaro et daniel prévost qui ont été
également les complices donc de jacques
martin lors de la mise en place d'une
émission qui fera date la création du
petit rapporteur pour les plus jeunes
d'entre vous il faut savoir que cette
émission était une petite révolution
lorsqu'elle fut lancé en 1975 un ton
décalé étonnant et détonant dans une
france qui découvraient ce nouveau
rendez vous françois jullien peignoir
aurélien chaplin
19 janvier 1975 un dimanche après-midi
un drôle de journal télévisé apparaît
sur les écrans
et dès la première édition le ton est
donné bonjour bonjour et si vous le
permettez bon dimanche ligne de
l'émission est un pied-de-nez à la
grande messe cathodique du journal de 20
heures autour de jacques martin une
équipe de journalistes déjanté les
petits rapporteurs s'appelle alors des
proches prévost bombe ou collaro
le concept des reportages qui tournent
souvent en eau de boudin
jacques martin a complètement innover à
l'époque la télévision était d'une très
grande timidité vis-à-vis du pouvoir en
particulier est dû par conséquent il a
été le premier à oser se moquer à une
heure de grande écoute du président de
la république pour remercier ses hôtes
sujet car les stocks au prix d'un grand
bruit
la rage la russie était en pays mais
qu'il y faisait part vraiment ton froid
pour la première fois je suis heureux de
vous montrer mon cul à la télévision 20
millions de téléspectateurs découvrent
mon cul ou cette interview de françoise
sagan par pierre desproges quand j'étais
en vacances ils ont beau frère ses
voiles à lons le chien ne trouve
cependant c'est un chien là c'est pas
nous c'est un chien l'avant une règle
dans l'émission l'improvisation
dimanche on arrivait à midi pour passer
à une heure il s'occupait des réglages
techniques mais entre nous ils nous
prennent et de rien et c'est pour ça
qu'il y avait une telle spontanéité dans
l'addition
l'émission s'arrête en juin 1976
l'équipe est soi disant fatigué
laventure aura duré 18 mois
mais le souvenir des sketches reste
éternelle avec nous également ce soir
daniel prévost bonsoir et merci de nous
rejoindre
tout d'abord vous avez beaucoup beaucoup
ri avec toute votre borne collaro des
proches pierre bonté oui on a beaucoup
ri mais je me souviens aussi qu'on a
beaucoup travaillé on était dans une
période de créativité intense de
création et on avait une imagination
fertile et je crois que c'est ça qui va
nous rester et beaucoup de on avait
beaucoup beaucoup de travail et de
fatigue également ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que le rire qu'on apportait
c'était un rire c'était un reer travail
et bien entendu on faisait pas on
faisait panne on ne faisait pas
n'importe quoi on on réfléchissait sur
ce que nous allions sur ce que nous
allions donner au public voyez-vous et
jeu que je retiendrai de jacques c'est
surtout un un saltimbanque magnifique
dans dans tout dans toute son acception
sert effectivement comme disait stéphane
il faisait tout et puis également il
avait un bagage culturel qu'il essayait
de faire passer à l'intérieur de son de
son discours face au public et je crois
que c'est le plus important
et c'était un musicien également vous
savez qu'il chantait je vous racontais
des lieux communs mais ils chantaient
admirablement et puis il imitait les
gens moi ce que je retiens c'est
l'artiste l'artiste l'artiste le très
complet
il imite ans les gens je me souviens il
imitait luis mariano dans une dans une
une opérette qui s'appelait petit
patapon qui avait été jouée à paris à
bobino et il était absolument admirable
il faut penser que c'était un type qui
jouait la comédie je les rencontre et
j'ai joué avec lui en 1963 62 il jouait
dans le misanthrope le rôle d' or on ne
sait pas si vous connaissez le rôle de
route du misanthrope sais pas si vous
connaissez le misanthrope de molière je
pense si vous connaissez molière mais
tout ça pour vous dire que c'était un
type tout à fait tout à fait formidable
et en même temps d'une très grande
culture voilà c'est ce que je retiendrai
de jacques et puis bien sûr il était son
propre chef d'entreprise c'est à dire
c'était un c'était un homme qui dirige
est très très bien toute son équipe 2-2
de jean farfelues parce qu'à l'époque on
disait farfelues on disait pas déjanté
comme maintenant déjanté woerth
strictement rien dire je vous dis tout
de suite parce lui ça veut dire quelque
chose
déjanté veux dire c'est au sujet d'une
roue on n'est pas des roues voilà mason
a dit jacques était magnifique
stéphane collaro lâche jamais jacques
martin ne vous censurez jamais ils vous
disaient oh là stop maintenant stéphane
kohler c'est stéphane que vous posez la
question oui stéphane collaro mais avoue
également si vous voulez tout me
parvient alors moi je voulais je n'y
avais jamais de search y avait jamais de
stop y avait eu il y avait au contraire
des des encouragements plutôt à se
défoncer et on avait besoin
d'encouragement parce que c'est vrai que
je me rappelle que quand on me demandait
d'aller attaquer le ministère de la
guerre en armure avec une manne une
masse d'armes en criant bigeard sort
site est un lâche
bon bah quand même il faut le faire avec
tous les crs tous les trucs donc entrer
qui nous poussaient surtout à nous
défoncer et je me souvient évidemment de
deux formidables parties de fou rire
avec jacques martin qui est le type le
plus gros le celtic qui m'a fait le plus
rire vraiment au monde parfois je me
tapais la tête contre les murs tellement
j'avais mal au ventre mais je me
souviens comme le dit daniel que le
petit rapporteur était également une
émission où on souffrait beaucoup parce
que c'était très difficile c'était
c'était vraiment un moment de tension
les reportages c'était assez compliqué
compliqué
et puis jacques martin avait un adage
c'était qui aime bien châtie bien
alors finalement l'on n'avait pas moi je
vais vous dire attendez une seconde sur
c'est moi qui veux vous parler
je veux dire ce que je retiendrai c'est
que c'était une
c'était une période où on n'avait pas on
n'avait pas de répit c'était bien qu'on
les sent on était censé sans création
permanente
voyez c'est à dire que du lundi au
dimanche après-midi et bien mon dieu on
travaillait et puis on avait le dimanche
après midi
on se reposait mais ce que je veux dire
également c'est que nous ne savions pas
à cette période que ce petit rapporteur
allait devenir mythique et c'est ce que
je souhaite à toutes les émissions
laurent gerra finalement toute cette
bande elle a un peu tout inventé ce que
l'on fait à la télévision par la suite
ce qu'on a fait c'est peut-être moins
impertinent beaucoup moins audacieux
finalement la pertinence sur une chaîne
publique comme ça une heure de grande
écoute
avec 20 millions de spectateurs c'est à
dire pouvoir se moquer du président de
la république je me souviens d'une scène
où giscard et avaient été reçus par à
présent chinois ils avaient juste fine
et c'est une totale mauvaise foi et film
est juste là jusqu'à en train de bouffer
de la purée des baguettes par exemple on
a ça c'était complètement aberrant de
faire ça il épuise avait demandé aux
gens aussi dans la rue de d'épeler
poniatowski qui était ministre à
l'époque et il n'y arrivait pas donc ça
c'était oui ils ont ouvert une brèche
qu'ils ont ouvert une brèche et puis je
me souviens que jacques martin disait à
dimanche prochain peut-être et je pense
que c'est une chose qu'il faut dire
aussi stéphane il faut dire aussi
quelque chose c'est que vous savez cette
histoire de la pêche aux moules
tout le monde a parlé de la pêche aux
moules on se marre les gens saluent ce
mouvement enfin s'amuse toujours en
disant à la pêche aux moules oms à la
pêche aux moules louis et la pêche aux
moules c'était c'était le symbole même
du petit rapporteur secteur la france
entière c'est à dire il y avait 45
millions lisant 60 millions de
spectateurs qui chantait la pêche aux
moules chez eux à balles à mes choix des
télécoms comme vous monsieur à une
certaine date
j'en avais tellement marre de la pêche
sur boule coach croit pendant un an j'ai
plus manger de moules bon d'oublier la
raison moi aussi
en tout cas d'accord c'est ça qu'il faut
retenir c'est nous qui vous remercions
merci à tous les trois pour vos
témoignages ce soir alors on l'a dit
jacques martin avait des talents
multiples extrêmement cultivé comédiens
chanteurs sur les scènes d'opéra comique
passionné de musique classique
il sera d'ailleurs la rente populaire
dans ses émissions quelques extraits des
talents d'un homme qui ne se trouvait
jamais vraiment à la hauteur marylène
bono et maryse richard ce plan commence
très exactement comme la bible par une
histoire de potes il en faut une
personne ou nuit voilà
sans bédié à qui tu donne des ordres toi
enfin quand même voilà tu vois est ce
que tu sens mais tombait
tu vois dossier de
moi personnellement je m'occupe de la
cuisse le vieux piano la place à des
clients dont l'habitude
et de danser amis
les autres jours seul sur les planches
devant la mer qui se souvient
sans feu
foulées basquaise pour en changer très
nettement le gorille ou je prends dans
la sauce du poulet basquaise jeu mais ce
qu'il faut de chez les groseilles
ces dames ont cherché 4 free ride
brian j'ai gâché gâcher ayala
voilà pour cette page spéciale consacré
à jacques martin jacques martin qui sera
inhumé jeudi prochain à lyon sa ville
natale ses obsèques seront célébrées en
la cathédrale saint jean dans le reste
de l'actualité en france cette erreur de
procédure aux lourdes conséquences
un homme condamné en octobre 2006 à 20
ans de réclusion criminelle est libre
aujourd'hui jacques maire c'est son nom
avait été condamné pour le meurtre de
deux jeunes femmes
le problème c'est une signature une
signature qui manquait en bas d'un
procès verbal et qui a donc entraîné
cette étonnante remise en liberté
stéphanie la fuente nicolas meyer c'est
un homme souriant et libre qui discute
avec son avocat jacques maire est sorti
hier de la maison d'arrêt il avait été
condamné à 20 ans de prison finalement
il n'a passé qu'un an derrière les
barreaux
car la cour de cassation a annulé le
jugement du tribunal d'epinal
je m'attendais quand même j'avais quand
même un sport à la cassation de
titration j'ai toujours clamé mon
innocence
la cour de cassation ne rejuge pas le
fond d'une affaire pour obtenir la
libération de jacques maire ses avocats
ont soulevé un vice de procédure
normalement le pv d'audience doit être
signé par la présidente et la greffière
mais cette dernière a oublié de parapher
une partie des documents une erreur de
plume qui réduit à néant tout le procès
le procès avait pu mal a été très
difficile il a bafoué vers la défense et
aujourd'hui effectivement la chambre
criminelle a sanctionné séparé le
condamnation jacques maire avait été
condamné en octobre dernier pour les
meurtres dans les années 80 2-2 jeune
femme odile busset dont le corps n'a
jamais été retrouvé et nelly adhérèrent
tué et mutilé aux mains et au visage
pour monique adhérèrent la remise en
liberté de celui qu'elle considère comme
l'assassin de sa soeur est intolérable
pour moi depuis deux années
on est persuadé que c'est lui les jurés
l'ont condamné quand maman alors c'est
pas parce qu'il manque une signature
innocent jacques maire va à nouveau être
jugé pour la même affaire il devrait
comparaître l'an prochain devant la cour
d'assises de metz justice toujours avec
les suites du procès de l'agression de
deux
reste dans la cité des tarterêts dans
l'essonne sept personnes comparaissaient
pour ces faits qui remontent à septembre
2006 est l'un des éléments qui marque ce
rendez vous judiciaire c'est la tension
la peur des représailles pour les
témoins aujourd'hui l'un d'entre eux a
même fait le choix d'intervenir sous x
une procédure rarissime que nous
explique audrey goutard et olivier
robert ils ont tous des ménages et
magistrats avocats victimes et prévenus
ont quitté ce matin la salle d'audience
direction cette pièce exiguë où trône un
écran de télévision
c'est ici qu'a été prévu l'audition du
témoin sous x
le seul témoin du lynchage de deux crs à
avoir parlé aux enquêteurs une audition
à huis clos car monsieur x risquent de
lourdes représailles s'il lui arrive
quelques soucis
le témoignage sous x une personne vous
ratés mais c'est parce qu'on se sera
rendu compte que finalement le x ne
protège plus rien et que en définitive
on peut néanmoins arrivait d'identifier
deux officiers de police judiciaire pour
protéger le témoin installé dans un lieu
tenu secret son audition va durer deux
heures il est d'abord interrogé par le
président qui ne peut le voir
sa voix est également brouillé mais on
sent ces hésitations par exemple qu'ils
aient pu identifier aussi facilement les
agresseurs alors qu'il se trouvait à
plus de 30 mètres du lieu
on estime que ce témoignage est un
témoignage qui s'autodétruit qui
comporte beaucoup de contradictions
comme on l'avait pressenti
reste que ce témoin clé a maintenu ses
accusations à l'encontre de six des sept
prévenus
l'audition de monsieur x a démontré une
fois encore la fragilité de ce type de
témoignage
pourtant sans ce système personne ne
serait venu se confier aux enquêteurs je
suis toujours avec le verdict rendu dans
la sphère des crs accusé d'avoir violé
des prostituées les trois accusés
principaux ont été condamnés à des
peines de sept ans de prison ferme par
la cour d'assises de paris
les policiers avaient reconnu les faits
et présenté leurs excuses social avec le
bras de fer entre les syndicats et la
direction de goodyear dunlop à amiens un
référendum sur la réorganisation du
travail était prévu auprès du personnel
mais cette procédure est la teneur de la
question n'était pas du goût de la cgt
qui a bloqué les portes des deux sites
de production
le référendum a finalement été annulé
avec 2700 salariés goodyear dunlop est
le plus gros employeur de la région
picarde sur place syriza et m'a dit ouah
personne ne passera deux heures du matin
des syndicats de vous dire d'un lob
bloquent l'accès au site
il refuse un référendum sur la
réorganisation du temps de travail
prévues aujourd'hui et demain les
conditions dans laquelle les directions
faire voter les salariés et les plus dix
mois quatre affiches qu'elle est en
train d'organiser comme dans un projet
voulu par la direction en jeu retour aux
40 heures hebdomadaires passage de cinq
à quatre équipes de travail avec pour
conséquence la suppression de 500
emplois sur trois ans les équipes de
nuit quittent le site
la plupart boycottera le vote vous êtes
contre ce référendum
il ya des familles
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui de
façon le nom l'emportera fortement
simplement façon on ne doit pas tolérer
la simulacre de vote comme la dia
chambre printemps aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aucun bulletin dans l'urne
pour la relève
impossible de rejoindre les ateliers on
va voir si on peut rentrer ou pas on va
attendre on va trouver 7h30 que les
cadres arrivent et on verra ce qui se
passera
et ce ne sont pas les cadres qui
viendront mais la direction ou des
sifflets elle annonce qu'elle fait
marche arrière
décision qui a été prise c'est de
d'annuler le référendum point à la ligne
les dirigeants de goodyear dunlop n'en
dirons pas plus ils envisageraient
désormais la réouverture de négociations
dans les ateliers
le travail a repris en début d'après
midi nicolas sarkozy et en hongrie
aujourd'hui le chef de l'état qui
souhaite tisser des liens nouveau avec
les pays d'europe centrale
même si lors de ce déplacement le
président de la république n'a pas
souhaité mettre en avant cette dimension
la hongrie est la terre de ses ancêtres
sur place alexandre kara francis forget
fanfare tapis rouge et honneurs
militaires en apparence un voyage
officiel comme les autres
pourtant pour nicolas sarkozy ce
déplacement est un peu plus qu'une
simple visite présidentielle
quand même pas oublier que la hongrie
c'est la patrie de mon père et que c'est
pas tous les jours qu'un président de la
république qui à moitié hongrois
moment fort de cette journée un discours
devant le parlement au milieu des
députés une vieille dame de 92 ans la
dernière représentante de la famille du
président en hongrie marianne sarkozy a
accepté de nous accueillir dans son
modeste appartement de budapest
elle nous montre des photos du grand
père de nicolas sarkozy avant de se
remémorer sa dernière rencontre avec son
petit cousin il y à plus de 40 ans j'ai
été fasciné par le regard du jeune
nicolas
j'ai dit à son père un jour c'est sûr il
sera un grand homme au mur est accroché
le dernier exemplaire des armoiries de
la famille elle représente un loup
brandissant un sabre elle porte un nom
bocsa boccia un village au coeur de la
hongrie c'est ici que se trouve le
véritable berceau familial des sarkozy
l'ancien maire se souvient de la visite
en 1994 de nicolas sarkozy venu à la
recherche de ses racines sur le livre
d'or de la mairie pour une fois il a
signé son nom en entier et qui a causé
des notebook
mais cette fois pas question de
pèlerinage familial
cette visite est resté strictement
protocolaire pour nicolas sarkozy c'est
surtout la première étape d'un tour des
pays européens avant la présidence
française de l'union
en juillet 2008 les temps sont durs pour
le sport français est un jeune homme
vient en tout cas de lui redonner le
sourire il a su être au rendez vous il
est même en avance puisque à seulement
18 ans teddy riner est devenu champion
du monde de judo des plus de 100 kg tout
cela s'est déroulé à rio de janeiro un
parcours exceptionnel puisqu'il a tout
simplement éliminer les favoris de la
compétition les uns après les autres
avant de le retrouver dans un instant
retour sur cet exploit avec manuel
tissier et zidène berkous à peine sortis
de l'adolescence
teddy riner entré dans l'histoire la
nuit dernière à rio de janeiro
le guadeloupéen est devenu à 18 ans le
plus jeune champion du monde des poids
lourds
vainqueur de l'idole japonaise inoue au
premier tour riner a écrasé le tournoi
jusqu'à la finale cette nuit au brésil
un junior api pouvoir
non là
le petit et vie est venu au judo pouvait
par les plus grands mais même david
douillet son modèle à qui il succède au
palmarès dix ans plus tard n'était pas
aussi précoce les deux géants se sont
croisés l'an dernier renner venait de
décrocher sa première couronne
européenne ce plaisir est quelque part
c'était des vocations ce top 2 mètres
0-2 130 kg ce géant jovial est un
sportif accompli basket boxe football
teddy riner est un touche-à-tout surdoué
mais un vrai passionné des tatamis ou sa
bonne humeur fait l'unanimité moi je
porte plutôt amusés dans le jeu j'essaie
d'avoir une joie de vivre le sourire
toujours eu cette nouvelle étoile tombe
à pic
il fallait au moins une montagne de
muscles pour cacher la toute petite
semaine du sport français
et avec ce gaillard là les sourires et
les médailles pourrait bien tenir
jusqu'aux jeux de pékin dans un an et on
retrouve le nouveau champion du monde en
duplex de rio de janeiro teddy riner
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous alors ça
y est vous avez réalisé enfin cet
exploit vous le réalisez vraiment
bonsoir j'ai un peu du mal à réaliser
mais je sais que c'est magnifique ce qui
est inhabituel ce que j'ai fait eh ben
je suis très heureux on dit que vous
êtes plutôt calme or des tatamis et puis
dès lors vous arrivez sur le tatami vous
devenez on va dire un vrai sportif de
compétition ça devient un autre homme
oui c'est vrai que en dehors du tatami
je reste serein et calme et puis dès
qu'ils vont monter sur tatami j'ai une
rage de vaincre et
envie de gagner je fais pas le mot alors
on pense obligatoirement un homme ce
soir david douillet qui était à vos
côtés je crois aujourd'hui est-ce que sa
présence a été importante
oui elle a été très importante parce que
lui il a déjà fait sa carrière il a il a
un autre point de vue il est plus neutre
et il a su m'apporter des points
techniques
tout au long de la compétition qui m'ont
été important et sera payé ça avec les
gens l'ont renversé
ça a payé vous savez que maintenant vous
avez une grosse pression sur les épaules
on pense déjà à pékin vous j'imagine que
c'est déjà un peu plus loin pour vous
dans votre esprit oui c'est pour
l'instant je pense pas j'ai encore un
mois de récupération où je vais fêter ma
médaille et puis prendre quelques
petites vacances et après on se remettra
dans le bas et on préparera sereinement
les jeux merci à vous en tout cas encore
bravo rendez vous donc à pékin pour ce
nouveau challenge la pression risque
d'être là bas un petit peu plus forte
avec ce type merci encore et bravo et je
vous le disais ce succès individuel
arrive au bon moment après deux défaites
collective en football et en rugby on
sait deux défaites qui d'ailleurs
regardez n'ont pas échappé à nos amis
britanniques qui aujourd'hui dans le
journal le guardian et dans un article
intitulé les misérables reviennent sur
ces jours difficiles du sport français
qu'il qualifie même de catastrophique
en tout cas pour tenter de redresser la
barre bernard laporte n'hésite pas à
remettre les compteurs à zéro en quelque
sorte puisque l'entraîneur du quinze de
france estime que la compétition
commence ce dimanche avec la rencontre
face à la namibie les joueurs français
qui n'ont plus qu'un mot d'ordre prendre
enfin du plaisir dans cette coupe du
monde affaire à suivre
sport toujours avec de la formule 1 l
épilogue de cette étrange affaire
d'espionnage qui touche l'écurie mclaren
des soupçons
nous sommes passés à la condamnation la
fédération internationale automobile a
infligée à l'écurie britannique
l'abandon de ces points au championnat
du monde des constructeurs et cela
également il faut ajouter une amende de
100 millions de dollars
retour sur une affaire qui mérite
quelques explications
julien b
tout c'était donc ça l'explication de
l'hégémonie des mclaren cette année
alonso et hamilton les deux pilotes
vedettes de l'écurie bénéficient des
secrets de fabrication du grand rival
ferrari cet après-midi les flèches
d'argent ont signé les deux meilleurs
temps des essais libres du grand prix de
belgique mais au championnat
constructeurs mclaren est désormais hors
course carrière à paris l'équipe
britannique a été reconnu coupable
d'espionnage par la fédération
internationale elle perd donc tous ces
points au championnat constructeurs et
devra payer une amende de 100 millions
de dollars
un cinquième de son budget malgré tout
ce qui a été dit à l'audience
aujourd'hui je maintiens que nous ne
méritons pas d'être pénalisé et de voir
notre image ternie de cette manière
pourtant la boîte mail d'alonso a
confondu l'écurie britannique dans son
courrier électronique
l'espagnol se vante d'utiliser des
réglages conçu par ferrari et pour cause
mclaren piocher certaines informations
dans un document confidentiel de 700
pages appartenant la scuderia dossiers
fournis aux anglais par un allié
inattendu un ingénieur de ferrari peu
scrupuleux licencié depuis dans la terre
alonso et hamilton s'en tire à bon
compte
ils gardent tous leurs points au
championnat des pilotes et vont donc se
disputer le titre mondial en toute
impunité
il suffit de prononcer son nom est déjà
son timbre de voix vous arrive aux
oreilles
maria callas la callas disparaissait il
ya 30 ans l'occasion de re découvrir la
chanteuse lyrique bien sûr mais
également la femme
le mythe la diva michel mompontet bruno
girodon maria callas
elle est morte il ya trente ans d'un
chagrin d'amour de l'arrêt du coeur
c'est selon il ya si longtemps c'était
un après-midi dans cette cage d'escalier
sa présence elle la divine la diva des
divas
elle vient sonner à une porte d'un
professeur de chant je vais ouvrir la
porte je vais vous soyez la bienvenue et
rentrer là dans le salon et mon piano
parce qu'elle est comme elle est janine
reiss ne prend pas de pincettes ni de
gants elle oublie la callas et ne parle
que de musique jeune mehdi encore comme
auch pu être assez stupide pour pour
être aussi simple et aussi décontracté
et faire mon métier comme je le faisais
des heures par jour et comme je prends
15 jours ce premier couvre à durer une
ou entre chanteuse porte fermée oreilles
ouvertes
je les raccompagner à la porte et là
puis une trees nerveuse absolument
incontrôlable
je me suis affalé sur le divan en me
disant oui mais quelle idiote tu peux
faire tu as reçu maria callas comme
n'importe qui d'autre tu l'a corrigé es
tu là enfin c'est très simple ne
reviendra pas
et elle va revenir toujours à 18 heures
dix ans durant le souvient de chaque
battement de mon coeur chaque battement
de son coeur
sow
et vous
bien sûr il y avait les triomphes bien
sûr il y avait son royaume et qui
s'étendait de la scala au metropolitan
opera en passant par la salle garnier
bien sûr il y avait toujours les
compliments encore les fleurs mais il y
avait surtout en embuscade
son exigence perpétuelle mais jamais
entendu lire mariam maria qu'elle était
contente de ce qu'elle faisait en garde
à toi mais c'est toi maria callas qui
aurait dû prendre garde à toi tu venais
de tomber amoureuse d'un prédateur le
milliardaire onassis maria callas
l'aimer lui
resterez peut-être à ces moments-là
regarder ailleurs
c'était aussi une femme qui pouvaient
aller par seulement en scène mais dans
sa vie privée jusqu'à la tragédie
connaissez vous madame amon schmidt
c'est sous ce faux nom qu'elle a choisi
de disparaître ici à paris c'était un
temps où en mourrez de chagrin d'amour
s'en sont vantés à la télé depuis 30 ans
madame rice attendent peut-être qu'une
nouvelle callas viennent à son tour
frappé à sa porte
et puis sachez que france 2 diffusera
demain à 15 heures un téléfilm sur maria
callas hommage à la diva également
dimanche à 18h30 à l'hôtel de ville de
paris où seront projetés c'est plus
grand concert voile avant de terminer ce
journal l'image du jour c'est celle bien
sûr de jacques martin homme orchestre du
petit rapporteur et artiste caméléon qui
a su pendant des années capter
l'attention du public 20 millions de
personnes regardent et son rendez vous
du dimanche à l'époque jacques martin
qui est mort la nuit dernière à l'âge de
74 ans voilà pour l'actualité de ce
vendredi
merci
me réjouis pas méchante elle a pris la
vie la vie
on dit merci à vous d'avoir suivi ce
journal je vous retrouve demain pour
l'information dans un instant la météo
nathalie rihouet ensuite le point route
avec valérie maurice 21h un numéro
inédit de votre série boulevard du
palais a passé une très belle soirée sur
france 2